someone told me JD talked about awkward
socially kissed wills wife on the lips
at Jason's party what's with you purpose
we were saying goodbye and we were like
I was trying to like I thought she
wanted to do to kiss on a cheek thing so
I leaned in and I guess I turned my head
or something and we our lips it was like
a perfect kiss but our lips did meet boy
it's fun to have JD at a party I was
trying to shake her hand and I
unfortunately put my finger in her [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
sorry wills wife hung high standing
alone and then I had a boner and I came
on her dress when you went in for the
kiss your lips met and then like do you
pull back or do you just hold back
immediately we started laughing and I
felt like what is funny about getting I
guess remember what did she say did she
go she was like she was laughing and and
we just said we acknowledge what
happened to everything I mean well it's
not like we were around people when it
happened so you were around Pete yeah I
didn't drag her into the corner so in
order to judge yeah he took that as a
signal when impregnate Will's wife does
we'll get to kiss your wife now those
are the rules he says he's never kissing
his wife again so like do you say to her
oh my gosh I'm so sorry yeah he felt bad
was it a sloppy kiss GD we did perfectly
meet like I thought we were kissing on
the cheek like the same goodbye I got
mixed signals or something Jan told me
you went up to Will's kids and said that
you introduced yourself as their new dad
or whatever call me uncle JD Kissin
uncle ah I got mixed signals
what kind of mix signal did you think
she wanted oh no what do you mean by
mixed signal I'll forget you know what
no no what is a mixed signal no like the
communication Scott cross like I you
have trouble communicating
alert the media